Hey youtubers it’s charlie and yesterday
in my episode 10 video I asked you to submit
all your walking dead questions.
Generally speaking everyone was most interested
in talking about lizzie, because we saw some
things that tied up a few bigger mysteries
from the first half of the season.
Quick shout out to this week’s giveaway
winner.
Congratulations to Farida Thomson, you win
a $20 amazon giftcard.
I’ll be reaching out to you on your channel
for details.
Don’t worry if you didn’t win.
Round 3 starts next sunday in my episode 11
video.
I’m also doing a weekly game of thrones
giveaway whenever that starts too.
Eventually I might even have t-shirts or something
to give away.
So careful for spoilers in these questions
if you haven’t seen the episode yet, but
let’s get started.
Question Number 1 - Jesse Wade asks Did you
think that Lizzie would have, either by accident
or on purpose, suffocated baby Judith while
trying to keep her quite in the woods?
I definitely thought she was trying to smother
her.
You could see her kind of slowly tune out
and her just covering judith’s mouth turned
into smothering.
It was really unsettling to watch.
I think it was partially unintentional.
She didn’t want to kill judith, but it’s
like when a little kid hits another one to
get them to stop crying and it only makes
things worse.
Lizzie just wasn’t processing that by closing
her hand around judith’s mouth she’d eventually
suffocate her.
Her brain just isn’t connecting those dots.
Question 2 - Ymir asks How long do you think
it will be before Lizzie (the sociopath) kills
someone in the group?
I don’t think it’s going to happen this
season, but I do think she’ll kill more
walkers.
Eventually someone is going to have to openly
address the issue that she’s gone a little
crazy before something really bad happens.
So I think Lizzie will continue to do really
effed up stuff that no one really notices.
Except for Carol.
Question 3 - DavijoMan asks Is Lily really
dead?
Yes, I think that’s what we’re meant to
believe based on Tara’s speech.
She didn’t explicitly state that Lilly was
dead, but she was out of bullets and she got
swarmed.
Tara kind of trailed off when she was mid-sentence,
so I think she watched while lilly got eaten.
Question 4 - Jonah Armitage asks What is Terminus?
Is that supposed to be Alexandria?
So there are two distinct places that the
groups go including alexandria which is the
safe zone and the sanctuary, which is where
the saviors are.
The episode was a little confusing because
the word ‘sanctuary’ kept getting used.
But in the comic books, they go to alexandria
first.
I think the alexandra storyline started around
issue 69, and the sanctuary storyline didn’t
start till around issue 104.
So considering that I think the terminus is
meant to be the sanctuary and they’ll split
the groups with some going to alexandria and
some going to the sanctuary.
Question 5 - Commander sloanne asks What would
have happened if Abraham & his group show
up before the Governor attack the prison?
I don’t think it would have changed anything,
it would have just gotten a little bloodier.
Abraham only had 3 people and it would have
taken a small army to keep the governor from
attacking with that tank.
Question 6 - David Mejia asks Carol, Tyreese
and the girls went one way, and Daryl and
Beth went the other, right?﻿
Yes, Carol and Tyreese headed toward the sanctuary
and daryl and beth went in the opposite direction.
Question 7 - shiskarobb asks Why didn't they
have an emergency meeting place?
I think because part of the prison arc the
first half of the season was that they had
stopped being soldiers and were trying to
settle down, so there was less of a sense
of urgency about where to go next.
I think they expected to stay at the prison
for forever just because it was so fortified.
So short answer, probably because they didn’t
think they needed one.
Question 8 - Josh Redgrave asks What are you
most afraid of for this season that you don't
want to happen?
The hunters getting their hands on Carl.
I won’t say how that goes, but you can check
out the comics.
Because it is not pleasant.
And the hunters in general are just an awful
bunch.
Just as bad as walkers themselves.
Question 9 - sixer asks Why did maggie laugh
at the end on the bus?
She was still in crazy mode but she was happy
and relieved that the walkers on the bus weren’t
glenn.
She thought he was on the bus.
So that’s why she was laughing like a maniac.
Maggie can go pretty crazy.
Question 10 - Careful for comic book spoilers
in this one, but it’s really good so I wanted
to answer it.
Cullen Bloodstone (no avatar) asks Do you
think the big thing lizzie ends up doing will
happen and then will the part with carl go
down like it does in the comics.
Given that the show changed what happened
to baby judith, I think they’ll change lizzie
and mika’s plot line too.
I think if they did it exactly like in the
comic book the audience would openly revolt.
Most of the people that watch the show don’t
read the comic book.
So they haven’t seen how bad things can
get.
I think that Lizzie will still do something
totally effed up, but they’ll tone it down
just a little.
Bonus question and last one - Legend of the
untitled asks Is it possible that lizzie is
the one who killed karen and david?
After seeing the rabbits
and then what she almost did to judith and
connecting her to the mutilated rats in the
prison.
Yes, she definitely killed karen and david
and Carol just covered for her.
I think Carol will explain to someone else
eventually what happened, but only after Lizzie
does something really really bad.
Thanks so much everyone for submitting your
questions.
This was a lot of fun as always.
Congratulations to Farida again for winning
the giveaway.
Everybody be sure to give her a high five.
I’ll be posting my next walking dead video
after episode 11 airs on sunday.
Be sure to subscribe to get it if you’re
just now finding me.
Right now click here for my review of the
episode and click here for my Game of Thrones
season 4 breakdowns.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!